pas besoin de passeport ni de valise
pour voyager avec les papilles je vous
emmène à Madagascar la Réunion est dans
les Caraïbes pour goûter le rhum arrangé
et toute sa palette de saveurs
d'une découverte en voyage Edouard vera
commercialisent aujourd'hui des mélanges
de fruits déshydratés et des pistes
auxquelles on ajoute simplement du rhum
il rend accessible chez nous ce qu'on
appelle le rhum arrangé quand j'ai
commencé à goûter à ça je me suis vite
pris de passion pour ce genre de
macération et d'infusion on peut être
vraiment créatif avec le rhum arrangé un
petit dicton qui dit qu'il y a autant de
rhum arrangé que personne qui en font
donc on peut faire du rhum arrangé
vraiment avec tout ce qu'on veut pour
guenaël Revel spécialiste des Roms la
liste des ingrédients qui composent un
bonhomme
trois ingrédients maximum enfin je veux
dire trois aromates maximum avec
peut-être une base de sucre il y en a
qui vont les affaires plus torréfiées
donc ils vont aller mettre peut-être des
grains de café ce qui préfèrent les
épices mettront plus de clous de girofle
la vanille est très plaisante parce que
elle adoucit puis ensuite on va utiliser
les fruits
[Musique]
là ici il y a trois ingrédients à la
pignon vanille et sucre on a des ananas
en pile
est-ce que c'est tout ce qu'on met dans
un romaringé c'est tout puisqu'il est
pas dans la Clara m'arranger c'est que
les ingrédients sont simples le
processus est simple mais c'est vraiment
d'avoir de la patience pour le laisser
le maturer ligne zebreux a des racines
haïtiennes là aussi le rhum arrangé est
bien ancré dans les traditions
chez moi la tradition c'est que ma mère
elle préparait toujours en préparation
d'une célébration donc pour le temps des
fêtes elle commençait vers le mot doux
elle met dans un endroit sec à l'ombre
et le laisse aller jusqu'au mois de
décembre il y en a une autre création
presque un remède
dans celui-ci quoi d'autre
et bien sûr vous avez
ça aussi moi je mettrais ça aussi dans
le chocolat chaud santé
[Musique]
on sent bien les fruits on a bien la
puissance de du rhum elle est là
la première saveur que je sens là je
voulais que vraiment dans cette recette
le combo des fruits exotiques ressortent
soit prédominant là ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ça reste fluide
c'est pas liquoreux c'est pas lourd moi
je conseille le rhum blanc en plus parce
qu'il est vraiment neutre en Go
traditionnellement en fait on va même
plutôt utiliser les Roms un peu plus bas
de gamme médiocre pour les améliorer
tout simplement leur donner vraiment des
mais le goût des fruits et des épices à
la fin du 19e siècle le rhum qui
voyageait avec les marins sur la route
des Indes était de piètre qualité donc
on avait pris pour habitude les familles
avaient arrangé elle-même leur
bouteilles de d'Europe simplement
qu'elles achetaient en mettant à
l'intérieur des fruits dont elle
disposées
traditionnellement associée à l'île de
la Réunion le rhum arrangé tirait ses
origines de Madagascar au gré des
migrations et de l'esclavage il s'est
rendu jusque dans les
il y a un autre produit qui est très
proche du rhum arrangé c'est ce qu'on
appelle le schrob lui est plutôt un rhum
avec une macération d'écorce d'orange ou
de mandarine ça vous allez surtout en
trouver en Martinique et ça on fait
plutôt à Noël
donc allons-y avec la dernière recette
pomme canneberge cannelle donc ici
l'inspiration plus québécoise des
saveurs qu'on retrouve ici plus
facilement très jolie ça sent Noël là on
est plus effectivement sur la saveur on
avance plus vers on avance plus vers les
fêtes dès qu'on met des bâtons secs là
la cannelle on l'a je pourrais le mettre
sur glace ou d'un sacré linge
c'est ça j'aime beaucoup celui-là
et ça c'est vraiment une recette typique
de ma maman on a notre homme arrangé
qu'on pourrait boire son glace ou comme
digestif mais qui va aussi servir à
faire la recette familiale
plus de 55 ans cette recette là dans la
famille ma mère me l'a appris on utilise
notre barrage on fait macérer nos
raisins pendant 24 heures et ensuite de
ça on fait le gâteau mais il y a pas de
liquide dans le gâteau à part le rhum
Myriam
ah c'est moelleux
j'avais peur j'adore pas les raisins
secs mais là il y a vraiment le côté
confit
on sent bien l'alcool quand même mais je
pense que le gâteau aux fruits va être
déclassé par le gâteau de la famille de
Lindsey brun c'est ce qu'on va entendre
[Musique]